with so much of
information available out there
including watching this video
i'm sure you've come across lots of
different advice
add in the fact that there are so many
fitness goals and
so many different ways to achieve those
goals it can get
really confusing on what works and what
is
just too good to be true so let's talk
about the seven common fitness
misconceptions
and separate facts from myth
let's get the facts right you can't turn
fat
into muscle there are two completely
different tissues
it's like saying i want to turn an apple
into a banana
it just doesn't work that way adipose of
fatty tissue is found
under the skin sandwiched between
muscles
and around the internal organs like the
heart
muscle tissue is found throughout the
body
what weight training does is that it
helps to build muscle
which encourages fat loss by increasing
your resting metabolism
one pound of muscle burns 7 to 13
calories
whereas one pound of fat only burns 2 to
3 calories
so if you have more lean muscles your
body will burn more calories
throughout the day hence looking slimmer
and leaner
i've also come across this question too
many times
can i work out and not diet basically
just eat whatever i want
how i wish this was true because i love
my food too
but unfortunately it's not i'm sure you
have heard of this saying
you are what you eat nutrition and diet
is
80 of the results we achieve even if you
spend
hours sweating and killing yourself in
the gym
but if you eat as much as you want after
then
you're just wasting all your effort and
you won't get the results you desire
say if you were to burn 500 calories
working out
but you were to consume a huge meal with
dessert
racking up to 1200 calories
then you're just undoing all your effort
to manipulate your weight up or down
it comes down to one simple principle of
energy balance
to lose weight you have to create a
negative energy balance
that means your total daily energy
expenditure
should be more than what you consume
that can be achieved by increasing your
activity level
and reducing your food portion
some people think they need to spend
hours of cardio in order to lose the
excess pounds
but they refuse to lift weights in fear
of becoming
bulky yes doing cardio is great for your
heart health
but it is not the most efficient way to
melt off
the fat and lean up i personally
rarely perform steady paced cardio as
i'm able to maintain my physique through
a combination of strength training
and heat exercises as i've mentioned in
my first point
strength training builds muscles and
muscles
burns more calories studies have also
shown that women who regularly engage in
strength training activity
will burn nearly 50 more calories
than their cardio queen counterparts
that translates
about an extra 100 calories expanded per
day
even when your body is at rest and
ladies
no you will not bulk up we have 15 to 20
times
lower testosterone levels than men
therefore becoming bulky just by adding
weights to our fitness routine
is highly unlikely instead adding weight
training will make
us stronger and shape our body on the
other hand
hit workouts are a great way to burn
more calories in a short period of time
you will also benefit from the after
burn the calories
you keep burning even after your workout
is done
it also helps to improve performance
such as explosive strength
agility and endurance saying that
however
hit workouts are not for everybody it's
not suitable for beginners or those who
have a history of injuries
and can even lead to overtraining hence
i would only recommend to perform
heat workouts two times per week
once again this goes back to the first
point fat cannot turn into muscles
and muscles cannot turn into fat there
are two completely different tissues
i think this myth came about because we
tend to see our super fit
sporting heroes becoming fat and out of
shape
once they stop training so what's really
happening
when you stop training you will lose
muscle mass
hence feeling less firm or toned
if you continue to remain inactive but
continue to consume the same amount of
calories
as previously then your body will start
to put on fat
because you are consuming more than what
your body is able to burn
with a decrease in muscle mass your
calories should also be decreased
as the caloric demand is no longer as
high as it previously was
when you were active if your calories
are not lowered
you will begin to slowly gain fat and
that is where the confusion
lies there is
no such thing as spot reduction you've
probably heard me saying this
over and over again yet
i keep receiving comments stating that i
only want to lose my hips
and belly fat even worse there are
workouts out there claiming that you can
get a flat belly in two weeks
or even a collarbone workout like
for real toning one area won't
just burn fat from that area and reveal
a slimmer sexier abs
when we lose weight we lose fat from our
entire body
you need to train the whole body and
keep your nutrition in check
covering the abdominals is a layer of
fat
hence healthy eating is the key to
minimizing fat
stores around the midsection depending
on your body shape
there will be areas of your body where
fat loss happens quicker compared to
other parts
these areas are just the stubborn areas
that
hold more fat which means further fat
loss
is required to see results in these
areas
of course by adding strength training
you can add
more muscle definition to your body but
that definition will only be visible if
you have a lower body fat percentage
remember the principle of weight loss
it's all about
energy balance whatever your goal is
whether to increase performance
or to pack on muscle you need good cups
and plenty of them i love my cups
and it has helped me to reduce my body
fat and lean up
cubs aren't the enemy a sedentary life
high sugar diet over dieting over
eating or having the wrong training
program are
if you were to follow a restricted diet
and were to eat your normal diet again
the weight will come back on and even
more
i've always been a believer of balance
and moderation
make healthier food choices consume a
balanced diet filled with whole foods
and take everything in moderation
i guess it's common for us to have the
more
the better mindset in fact i've known of
trainers who trained their clients
six to eight hours a day in order to
produce
fast weight loss results for a fitness
competition yes
they did lose a lot of weight within the
time frame of the competition
however what you have to ask yourself is
is this lifestyle sustainable and what
will it do to their long-term
mental and physical health the people i
know have gained
more weight after the show and it has
impacted their self-esteem
the truth is they can't keep up with
their workout and sustain it for life
over training can also result in extreme
fatigue
low energy mood swings hormone imbalance
injuries and a decline in performance
it's gonna do
more damage than good having enough time
for your muscles to recover is extremely
important
for you to perform at your optimum and
to see permanent results
a solid workout should last between 45
minutes to an hour
if you find yourself spending longer
than that then you should really review
your training
are you spending more time training or
taking long breaks
on your phone or catching up with your
workout buddy
this list could go on and i'm sure you
might have come across
other fitness misconceptions or perhaps
you might have questions
which you're unsure of let me know in
the comments below
the bottom line is there isn't one
method fits all
the more you learn about your own body
through nutrition and training
and the more you educate yourself in all
areas of fitness
the better you will be in creating and
implementing
these informations and techniques that
will help you achieve
your fitness goals if you enjoyed this
video then give this video a thumbs up
share this video on and be sure to hit
the subscribe button
check out my youtube channel for a lot
more fitness tips nutritional tips
healthy recipes and workout videos and i
will see you in my next video
all the best